hola
con rocas de paredes de neumáticos
manifestantes montenegrinos bloquearon
el acceso a la vieja capital de setting
e
intentaban evitar sin éxito la ceremonia
de coronación del nuevo líder religioso
que la iglesia ortodoxa serbia celebró
allí
los manifestantes se enfrentaron a la
policía antidisturbios al grito de esto
no es serbia y viva montenegro
la ceremonia de este domingo exacerbó
tensiones étnicas en el país balcánico
ya que muchos consideran que la iglesia
es un símbolo de influencia serbia
también se convocaron contra marchas
durante el sábado en podgorica para dar
la bienvenida a los religiosos
[Música]
estamos escribiendo la historia y
luchando por nuestra fe no le imponemos
nada a nadie solo estamos aquí para
apoyar al patriarca siempre estaremos
con la fe ortodoxa y siempre creeremos
en dios siempre estaremos con nuestra
iglesia nuestra fe y espero que hoy en
la catedral todo transcurra sin
problemas como siempre
montenegro declaró la independencia de
serbia en 2006 pero su iglesia no obtuvo
la autonomía
durante semanas opositores de la iglesia
ortodoxa serbia han pedido que la
coronación se celebra en algún otro
lugar pero la institución religiosa lo
rechazó
el cristianismo ortodoxo es la religión
dominante en el país y los montenegrinos
independentistas quieren una iglesia
propia separada de la serbia
de hecho la iglesia serbia jugó un papel
clave en las manifestaciones que el año
pasado provocaron la caída del gobierno
occidentalista en montenegro el nuevo
gobierno ahora incluye partidos pro
serbios y pro rusos